[Music]
for native americans it was the source
of myth and legend
early promoters nicknamed it wonderland
[Music]
today it's one of the last great
wildernesses
accessible to anyone lucky enough to
travel here
most come in the summer when it's warm
that sunrise light is just gorgeous
incredible
we came in january
when it's not
you know so often when i'm out like this
i consciously think to myself
this is it right here right now it just
doesn't get any better than this and
you've been thinking the same thing for
45 years 45 years as far as we can tell
69 year old jeff henry knows more about
yellowstone than any other person alive
indeed the highlights will be a fishing
guide here on yellowstone lake i've
worked maintenance i've worked as a
truck driver i've worked as a tour guide
a snow coach driver a grizzly bear
researcher a coyote researcher a park
ranger a park resource manager henry is
also a photographer and author having
written eight books about yellowstone
including his latest yellowstone
national park the first 150 years
the title can be deceiving since the
book begins discussing the area's
ancient geologic riches
yellowstone today remains the world's
largest volcanic system with more than
ten thousand hydrothermal features
constantly releasing pressure
yellowstone has looked pretty much like
it looks now
since the ice of the last period of
glaciation melted away and that was
about 14 000 years ago that's around how
far back humans can be traced here
for critters
it's a lot longer
waiting for some coyotes
to come up
we're not gonna interrupt them we're
gonna let them pass by and
go enjoy their dinner
i would like to enjoy my dinner right
now
i'm hungry
[Music]
many roads throughout yellowstone are
not plowed in winter most people and
supplies are transported by snow coaches
which are also a great way to spot the
largest collection of mammals in the
lower 48.
1884 the buffalo population dwindled to
only 24 in the entire park
today
there are about five thousand the frost
build-up actually protects them i think
it's an indication that their coats
extremely warm they're very well
insulated
this one guy is just staring me i mean
he doesn't he's like why are you guys
am i supposed to be worried about you
guys or not
it's not their nature to look for
trouble it's mine
snowmobiles are also an essential travel
tool
allowing henry to complete the critical
task he devotes his time to these days
as one of the park's winter keepers
clearing rooftops of snow
so buildings don't collapse
this is the greatest sport in the
history of the world jeff
clearing snow from rooftops it is
something jeff henry is obsessed with i
love to play basketball i love to play
football i love the ski
love all those sports
but i give them all up
if i had to to do this
nice
you've done all these incredible things
in your life and seen more of this place
than i think anybody and yet
the most fascinating
fun thing for you is removing snow
from rooftops i know it's eccentric and
you can go ahead and laugh at me if you
want to
but yeah it gives me a thrill i've done
it for 44 winters and i get more of a
kick out of it now than ever if that's
possible
big boy
yeah the greatest sport in the history
of the world
it's art for you it's it's sport it is
it's math
it is it is how much did each one of
those pieces weigh do you think
and some of my friends joe could say i'm
like the rain man because they do
arithmetic problems in my mind
and i have a good memory for whatever
reason 500 pounds
snow clearing also helps if you want
access to the grand view of
yellowstone's most famous site from on
top the old faithful inn
this is not only the best place to look
at old faithful from but it's the best
time of year i think oh i agree
because right now you got maybe
i don't know 50 60 people down there in
the summer you'd have
oh thousands absolutely it was from this
vantage that henry then a ranger
witnessed and photographed the largest
fire in the park's history in 1988
nearly 800 000 acres burned
the fire was so hot when i topped that
ridge over there i could feel the
radiant heat from the flames
it made it even more scary because there
was so much smoke most of the time you
couldn't see the flames you could hear
the wind you could hear the flames and
then just every once in a while the
smoke would part and you could see these
gigantic flames that were like three
times as tall as the forest
there she goes
almost looks even better in the winter
because you get all that from the cold
air the steam yeah i mean think about it
sometimes it's 40 50 below zero out here
and that water is close to 200 degrees
above so the differential is what 250
degrees
today jeff henry has become not just a
living legend at this park
but a teacher and mentor for the next
generation
you're stronger than the shovel handle
you can easily break
including for young guys
like nadia garbage so now making this
right turn we've come off the grand loop
road and we're going to cross over the
yellowstone river here
what is it about yellowstone for you
i think
yellowstone has an addictive quality of
magnetic force i'm
addicted to this place it
speaks to me i've been so fortunate to
travel over the world
and i think nothing compares to
yellowstone some people they check in
here discover it's a volcano
and then leave i know it sounds crazy
as you can see from the steam we are
inside of a volcano and yes it has
happened i have friends who won't visit
me family who won't visit me they're
just too scared to visit inside of the
largest most violent super volcano in
the world what better place to be
[Music]
it's been over 640 thousand years since
the last super eruption
helped form these awe-inspiring
landscapes
[Music]
they are things no matter the season
jeff henry and the millions who come
here
can't imagine living without
[Music]
and you have a thing with the cold
weather where you you just say it's not
going to let it beat you again for
whatever reason that's my personality
i'm a determined individual
and i like challenges thrown up in front
of me
the harder the wind's blowing the colder
it is the deeper the snow is the harder
the conditions the better i like it
because i'm just not going to let it get
the best of me and you're yelling at the
weather
i do i remind myself of lieutenant dan
in the movie forrest gump when he was on
top of the mast of his shrimp fishing
boat and he was screaming at the storm
it's time for a showdown and i find
myself doing that very thing on top of
some of my buildings sometimes when i'm
when i'm clearing the snow off the
buildings i'll stand up on the roof and
yell at the wind
i dare you to try to stop me let's see
if you can stop me
you